各位开发者大家好,欢迎大家参与升腾看技术课程的学习
本节课是Triton算子开发的进阶课程
会带领大家掌握Triton的编程范式
以及面向升腾开发算子的关键点
本次课程分为四个章节
分别是面向升腾开发与迁移
Triton算子调试方法
Gather算子用力解读和Triton算子自动调优
我们首先来看第一部分
面向升腾的开发与迁移
我们先来回顾一下Triton Kernel的开发模式
回忆一下一个Triton Kernel
以及它的调用大体上是什么样子
在Triton的编程框架中
用户会对数据还有计算任务做切分
程序会自动发射多个逻辑核来处理切分后的数据
根据逻辑核的数量
数据被切成多个block
不同的block最终会在物理核上进行并行计算
Triton采用的是SPMD的开发模式
在SPMD开发模式中
所有逻辑核会共用同一段Triton Kernel的代码
而在Kernel内部会完成一个block的对应计算任务
那么从外向里看
调用并执行一个Triton Kernel
要经历哪些流程呢
首先需要在调用Kernel前
创建并初始化好Tensor
此时Tensor中的数据处于偏外内存
之后就是调用Triton Kernel
在调用时有一个关键参数Grade
这个参数可以控制3D范围内每个轴上发射的逻辑核的数量
完成了算子的调用
我们一起来看一下Kernel内部的实现
在Kernel内第一步通常是去获取逻辑核的ID
然后根据逻辑核的ID和block的大小
计算出切分数据的偏移值
确定目标数据的位置
之后把数据加载到偏让内存执行计算
最后再将数据搬回片外
这就是Triton Kernel
算子实现和算子调用的整体模式
原生Triton的出现是为了降低GPU的算子开发难度
Triton Ascend已经完成了Triton DSL和升腾的适配
只需要少量的代码调整
就能使算子在升腾运行
我们先来整体看一下有哪些适配关键点
首先在Kernel内部实现上
Triton Ascend深度兼容了原生社区接口
这意味着它直接附用了原生Triton的开发范式
包括函数定义、逻辑组织等
大家在编写算子时
可以直接查阅原生Triton的官方文档
作为参考
下面这里需要注意
设计片上内存的使用存在着约束
正如Triton计算流程中提到的
在计算开始前
我们需要显示的将数据从片外搬运到片上内存中
因为片上空间是有限的
所以我们不能一次性将超过片上内存容量的数据
全部搬运进来
这会导致内存溢出
更详细的内存使用技巧
会在后面的章节展开讲解
接下来我们聚焦于
外层Kernel调用的适配
首先
创建Tensor的时候
需要将使用到的PyTor接口的后端关键词
切换为NPU
其次
在调用Kernel的时候
用于控制逻辑核数量的Grade参数
其有效取值范围存在特定约束
会在后面的课程中进行详细的介绍
学习了Triton的开发模式和算子迁移技巧
下面我们来看一下常用的Torch接口
进行算子迁移需要做哪些适配
核心逻辑其实非常简洁
对于大部分Torch API调用
大家只需将代码中所有硬件
相关的关键词统一替换为NPU
系统便会自动调用TorchNPU插件
来完成适配
同时为了确保算子
能正确调度到升腾硬件上运行
无论是Tensor创建
设备指定
还是同步
等待等需要指定设备的操作
请牢记
要在Device参数上显示指定为NPU
接下来我们讲解一下Grade的配置策略
首先
在定义方式上
Grade的维度
既支持直接硬编码
也支持动态计算
它的核心作用是
宏观上控制多核并行的规模
目前Triton Ascend的框架
与Triton原生社区标准保持一致
最多支持3DGrade的设置
如果开发者错误地
使用了更高维度的Grade
比如5V
程序虽然不会报错
但底层会自动丢弃
超出前三个轴之后的所有维度
仅保留前三个轴进行计算
这会导致计算逻辑与预期不符
而且我们强烈不建议进行
3D以上的并行拆分
毕竟Triton的设计初衷是简化开发
过度的轴拆分会让代码的控制更复杂
在大多数场景下并无必要
在拆分技巧上有两条核心建议
第一
控制拆分力度
避免过多的轴拆分
以减少代码逻辑负担
并且优先对高维轴进行切分
而保留低维轴的完整性
原因是这样做能确保
每个逻辑核内部处理的数据
在内存中具有更好的连续性
从而最大化内存访问效率
举一个反面案例
如果将最后一位完全切分
那么每个kernel仅计算一个数值
会严重破坏数据连续性
导致计算资源的浪费和性能的下降
当然规则并非绝对
比如当伪轴长度极大
甚至超过了偏上内存的容量时
为了避免内存溢出
此时必须对尾轴进行切分
总之
Grid的拆分轴
选择需要根据开发者实际数据的
Shape灵活权衡
第二
除了基础的轴拆分
我们还需要掌握并行轴的合并技巧
以应对特殊场景下的性能瓶颈
当遇到某些带拆分的轴长度过短时
如果直接按轴长设置并行
会导致部分物理和闲置
无法发挥NPU的并行优势
此时我们可以采用逻辑合并
物理还原的策略
在定义Grid时
将多个较小的并行轴
在逻辑上合并为一个更大的维度
传递给Kernel
从而凑足并行度
而在Kernel内部
则利用PID配合整除和区域运算
将这个合并后的大PID逆向分解
重新映射回原始各个轴的独立索引
举个例子
若需对Scale0和ScaleE两个轴并行
我们可以将两者的长度相乘
作为单一维度传入Grid
在算子内部
通过PID整除ScaleE Lens
获取Scale0的索引
通过PID对ScaleE Lens
取以获取ScaleE的索引
这种写法既绕过了单周长度不足的限制
最大化了硬件吞吞吐量
又保证了多位数据访问逻辑的正确性
了解了Grid周配置策略后
接下来我们重点讨论Grid的取值策略
首先
受限于底层优引的16数据类型的表达上限
Grid的单位最大值不能超过6535
超出该预值将直接触发报错
在性能优化层面的核心技巧是
尽可能用满物理核
需要明确的是
Grid定义的只是逻辑并行实力的数量
而非真正的同时执行能力
实际的并行度取决于NPU上的物理核数量
比如用于矩阵计算的cube核
和用于向量计算的vector核
如果我们将Grid设置的过大
会导致大量的逻辑核排队
等待物理核资源释放
从而引发严重的串行等待现象
这不仅无法提升速度
反而会因为编译器
需要进行复杂的任务调度
与资源分配
产生额外开销
最终导致算子整体性能大幅下降
举例来说
若算子仅包含矩阵运算
其最大并行度受限于cube核的数量
例如硬件有40个cube core
则最多只能有40个逻辑核同时运行
若算子仅包含下量运算
最大并行度则受限于vector核的数量
例如硬件有80个vector core
则最多80个逻辑核
实际并行
即便我们发射了更多的逻辑核
也不会增加真实的并行度
因此最佳的实践是
将grade的大小设置为物理核数量
或在此基础上进行微调
以此确保算子的高效运行
当算子同时包含矩阵和向量计算时
我们需要以稀缺资源为基准
来设定并行度
在当前版本升腾架构中
cube与vector的数量比例为1比2
由于cube数量较少
我们需要以cube的数量来设置grade
此外需要注意的是
这里还存在一个限制
就是一个逻辑核不能拆分
运行在多个同类型的物理核上
如果发射的逻辑核数量是物理核数的一半
就会有一半的物理核资源未被使用
需要避免grade的设置过小
但如果算子同时包含矩阵和向量运算
是个cube vector融合算子
由于当前cube和vector核数是1比2
一个逻辑核可以使用一个cube核和两个vector核的资源
我们要记住这条资源匹配的原则
如果你的逻辑核数量少于物理核数量
实际并行度即为逻辑核数量
若多于物理核
多出的部分必须排队等待调度
为了帮助大家更精准的控制并行度
我们提供了Traton Runtime Driver
支持在算子启动前获取当前设备的物理核资源信息
具体使用方法如代码中所示
首先通过Driver接口获取Current Device
再调用Get Device Properties API
该API会返回详细的硬件属性
开发者可以根据需求
查询特定字段
比如查询NumAI Core字段
来获取Cube核的数量
查询NumVectorCore字段
来获取Vector核的数量
我们建议将这段代码写在算子外部
在正式调用Kernel之前执行
通过这里获取的核数
设置算子调用时的Grade参数
Traton算子开发与迁移调优
与升腾硬件架构密不可分
接下来带大家了解升腾的硬件架构
在当前的升腾架构构构中
Vector单元与Cube单元是物理隔离且独立运行的
它们各自拥有专属的计算核心标量处理单元以及独立的存储层级
如图所示
右上方的AIC核主要包括Cube单元、Scalar单元以及各级存储
其中Cube单元用来进行矩阵运算
Scalar单元负责地址计算、逻辑判断等辅助任务
各级存储用于存储矩阵计算的数据
其中LEBuffer作为片上高速缓存
用于暂存频繁复用的数据
起到片外内存与核心计算之间的高速缓冲作用
L0A、L0B和L0CBuffer
这是矩阵运算的核心数据区
对应矩阵乘法
L0A用来存放输入矩阵A
L0B用来存放输入矩阵B
L0C用来存放计算结果
C图示右下方的AIV核主要包括Vector单元、Scalar单元以及Unified Buffer存储
其中Scalar单元与AIC中的功能相似
Vector单元用来进行向量运算
Unified Buffer存储用于向量计算的数据
简称UB
这是Vector核的主要工作内存
所有的向量输入数据需先从全局内存搬运至UB
Vector核的结果也暂存于UB
最后再写回全局内存
全局内存在图中对应的是最左侧的global memory
简称GM
是所有kernel共享的偏外内存
讲解完硬件架构
我们接下来重点介绍偏上内存的使用规范
在讲Triton编程范式的时候
我们提到过
需要开发者手动控制数据
在偏外内存和偏上内存之间的load和store
这里提到的偏外内存指的就是GM
偏上内存是指AIC核中的LEBuffer和AIV核中的UB
偏上内存的容量相对较小
单次计算任务占用的内存一定不能超出物理上限
否则会导致运行失败
这里我们介绍一些技巧
首先在处理切片的时候需要综合考虑block size与grade size
当遇到内存超限
第一反应往往是缩小每个逻辑核处理的数据量
也就是block size
但总数据量是固定的
如果缩小block size为了覆盖全部数据
就必须增大并行块的数量
也就是grade size
就像我们前面提到的那样过大的grade size
会导致逻辑核数远超物理核
引发串行等待和调度开销
极端情况下甚至会直接触发Uint16上限报错
因此单纯缩小block size并非两侧
正确的解决方案是在单个kernel内部进行二次切分
即在保持grade和block不变的情况下
在每个逻辑核内部将大数据块进一步拆解为更小的子块
分批次搬运到偏人计算
这样做的优势是确保同一时刻
注留在偏上内存中的数据量
始终在安全范围内
既避免了内存溢出
又维持了合理的并行度
在进行切片时
我们建议将切片大小设置为32字节对齐
最好是2的密
这能有效避免标量指令处理边界的情况
可以消除尾块填充
带来的额外开销并提升效率
在对kernel内分块大小进行调试时
我们建议利用编译器的反馈来进行优化
这是因为
由于算子内部不仅包含输入输出数据
还涉及中间变量
寄存器占用以及编译器自动进行的内存浮用优化
开发者很难通过人工粗略计算精准判断内存是否超限
所以不要进行人工估算
可能有时候我们觉得内存超了
但编译器的复用优化已经将使用的内存缩小到了线之内
反之亦然
这里我们提供了详细的包锁机制
当内存超限时
系统会明确告知超限的位置
是Ub超限还是L1超限
当前写法需要多少空间
而硬件实际提供了多少空间
根据这些精确的反馈信息
反向调整subtiling参数
可以快速找到内存的平衡点
这里为大家贴了一个实现案例
核心的思路非常简单
第一步引入参数
在代码中新增subblock size参数
用来定义内部紫切片的大小
把这个加到参数的好处是
可以通过autochune对它的值进行自动调优
第二步核内负循环
利用这个参数加一个负循环
在这个循环里程序会轮流
把那些更小的subblock数据搬运进来进行计算
算完一块就立刻把结果写回到gm
然后继续处理下一块
直到所有数据处理完成
下面我们来讲解一下multibuffer性能优化机制
在高性能算子开发中
有时瓶颈往往不再计算
而在于数据搬运
通过multibuffer我们可以让计算单元和数据搬运单元
并行工作
当计算单元在处理当前数据块时
翻译单元已经在预取下一块数据了
这种重叠执行能显著隐藏内存延迟
提升整体吞吐
当前编译器中默认开启了multibuffer策略
但需要注意multibuffer仅在坑头中包含循环时
才会自动生效
这也很好理解multibuffer需要至少两次数据加载
计算写回的流程才可能产生性能收益
此外开启multibuffer相比不开会占用更多的片上内存
multibuffer开启时kernel中同时存在的数据总和
不能超过96kb
关闭后不能超过192kb
当然也不是在所有场景下multibuffer都会得到正收益
所以在实际的算子开发中
开发者可以主动选择是否关闭这一选项
这里提供两种标准的控制方式
方式一通过AutoChune配置注入
在使用AutoChune进行最优config搜索时
可以直接在config字典中设置multibuffer等于true或者等于false
方式二调用时直接指定
如果开发者已经确定了最佳策略
或者在调试阶段想强制关闭它
可以直接在调用kernel时指定参数multibuffer的值